foreign
Jimmy Johnson the Hall of Famer he has a
new book called Swagger Super Bowls
brass balls and footballs a memoir
recounting his great career life and
lessons on winning you can get your copy
online wherever books are sold Jimmy
good to have you back on what's the
worst weather you ever coached in
oh Dan uh well when I was at University
of Pittsburgh we had you know we had a
couple of feet of snow when we played uh
Penn State
um and a few cold games when I was with
the Cowboys going up to play play the
Giants but you know really no horrible
horrible weather I I wasn't uh half the
coach uh when we were in bed I looked
like the Michelin Man on the sideline
trying to stay warm that's why you took
the Miami job exactly right that's why I
live in the Florida Keys uh tougher to
replace Tom Landry or Don Shula
well you gotta you know both of them
great great coaches but you know Tom
Landry had had three straight losing
seasons and his last season before we
got there was 3 and 13 which was the
worst in the league uh and so I think
people were ready you know to make a
move and you know when I got there you
know you know like I said you know he's
a great football coach but they just
didn't have any talent and uh going
Shula they got beat in the playoffs you
know right before and you know people
talked to him about him retiring as well
um obviously difficult replacing either
one of them but I always told people I
said hey they they both were great great
coaches Hall of Fame coaches you know
but just let me do my thing
what was it that you did that was
different
yeah the one thing that I always tried
to you know really concentrate on was
you know bringing in Talent
um evaluating talent uh and that's we
have people come down to the Keys you
know coaches general managers owners not
only football but you know baseball you
know people basketball people and they
said you know what was the key for you
as far as evaluating talent uh in
building a team and so you know when I
was at Oklahoma State when I was at
University of Miami I was my own
Personnel director and and I personally
uh evaluated the players before we ever
signed them or drafted them Etc and so I
think Personnel was as much as anything
else in building a team okay but how do
you do that I mean it's all in the eye
of the beholder but you were seeing
something that was different than a lot
of other coaches and GMS were
well you know I emphasize certain things
you know number one was Intelligence I
mean you look at the first four picks
you know uh when I went to the Cowboys
Troy Aikman academic All-American you
know Daryl Johnston academic
All-American Mark stabnoski academic
All-American Tony Tolbert academic
All-American you know that's in the
first four rounds and you know those
players get better and better you don't
have the problems off the field uh they
improve as time goes on and they really
contribute I always said you know I look
for five things I said number one is
intelligence number two I wanted a gym
rat I wanted somebody that was going to
compete you know somebody making a
difference it was shooting pool or pick
up basketball they wanted to compete and
the other thing is I wanted a worker
that uh had passion for what they were
going to do that would willing to work
around the clock or see Beaufort for
instance uh general manager of the Spurs
and he's been down here twice
and he said you know Pop's going to
retire when he says would you be
concerned about a college coach you know
what do you look for in hiring somebody
I said it's no different than what I
talk to companies about you know and
hiring workers and you know hiring
people for any company I said give me
somebody that's intelligent
give me somebody that's got passion for
the job that really wants to put
themselves totally into it and give me
somebody that's willing to work around
the clock to get the job done I don't
care what they know if they don't know
anything about the job they'll learn
what to do and they'll know they'll
learn how to do it so give me those
three things and you're going to have
somebody that's going to be successful
why write a book now
well you first of all you know with all
the people coming down
coming down by attorney Nick Chris and
say hey you got
to read
after I got it
we started not only talking about the
talent and building the team we started
talking about the struggles you know
that I went through and my family went
through you know what yeah both of my
sons played football I never saw either
one of them play a game and you know it
the book was almost an apology to my
sons and my family that hey I would have
liked to have been there before you but
I was always trying to win a
championship I always felt like I had to
outwork the opposing coach and so in
some ways it was apology to my family
and and I talked to my boys about it and
they said hey daddy says we understand
we would have loved to have had you
there uh but by the same token we
benefited from all those you know
successes that you had not the one son
Chad in fact there's a chapter in the
book about it you know he suffered
through alcoholism for many years and uh
he went through recovery and started a
rehab center in St Petersburg tranquil
Shores now he's got a second one right
outside of Austin tranquil Hills super
successful and it's really really
rewarding for me to put that in the book
but how did how much did you beat
yourself self up over that you know do
you take responsibility ability in some
way that your son became an alcoholic
I I don't know that you know
my wife Rhonda
Ron herself and
and too much responsibility for that
but the only thing I say Dan is if I'd
have been there maybe I could have
nipped it in the bud
you know probably the most emotional I
think I've ever been they have a client
reunion uh they're at tranquil Shores
and I've been there three or four times
and they have the mothers and daddies of
the clients that are in recovery go up
and speak at the podium and mothers and
days will get up and I'll be sitting
next to Chad there in the audience and
they'll say Chad
thanks for saving my son's life
one lady got up and said Chad you picked
up my daughter at two o'clock in the
morning drove her around for four hours
talking to her counseling with her and
then Tucker to detox thanks for saving
my daughter's life I mean I'm sitting
here teared up you know and sitting next
to Chad and then I've got to talk I've
got to finish it up and I said listen
you know I won national championships
you know I won Super Bowls and I said
nothing that I've ever done can compare
to what y'all are doing saving lives
well you look at the I know I've talked
about this on on my show about being at
SportsCenter I was working second shift
for 15 years and missed out on an awful
lot and and you never my wife said stop
beating yourself up but it's hard to say
that and you know your kids I have four
kids but you still you hold it in and
you're like God I was I selfish and you
sort of run you know try to find the
balance there and I don't know if
there's a balance in in what we do or
coaching and other professions yeah you
know I speak to companies all the time
and and you know I visit with the CEOs
and the presidents and Etc et cetera
and the thing that I found out people
that are really successful you know
ahead of these companies they don't put
in just 40 hours you know they sacrifice
yeah they have their struggles just like
so it's not just in sports it's not just
hit football coaches I think sometimes
head football coaches take it a little
bit to the extreme sleeping in the
office and stuff but but really anybody
really successful they got to put their
whole body into it it can't be just a
40-hour week he's Jimmy Johnson the Hall
of Famer and the new book is Swagger
Super Bowls brass balls and footballs a
memoir you can get it online wherever
books are sold
I've spoken about this many many times
on the show that not everybody who's a
great coordinator should be a head coach
the difference between being a
coordinator and a head coach on a
day-to-day basis is what
Ron dable called and we talked for about
an hour uh and he asked he said you know
what's the best advice you can give me
I said Brian I said you know you've been
a great coordinator X's and O's and you
know schemes
I said but when you had walked down that
Hall
nobody cared you know if I gave a damn I
said but now
you're the head coach you're the leader
you walk down that Hall and every head
will turn
if you're going to get the best out of
the organization you've got to have
interaction because let me tell you what
no one wants to be ignored by the leader
and I said you've got to have
interaction with the secretary with
Administrative Assistant with their
backup offensive guard with the intern
coach it doesn't always have to be
upbeat and possible but I have some
interaction you know make sure
everybody's on the same page and I was
so impressed with Brian one of the
things he said oh yeah he said in fact I
took Pizza down to the equipment guys
just the other day and I said yeah get
them all on the same page
but you put in more time college or uh
NFL as far as a head coach
Brad y'all asked me on the show one time
and said you know how about the
differences too I said Terry
there's not a world of difference
between college coaching and pro
coaching there's a galaxy of difference
it is I mean the length of the scene
when you're the head coach of a college
you know especially one of those top 12
schools you're a father figure you're a
mentor you know you've got young kids
that left home for the first time in
their life they got girlfriend problems
so you're in your office counseling them
you know now in professional football
hey it's you know the parody it is so
close between the best and the worst if
you don't go out there and play well
you're gonna get beat
but that doesn't happen in the top
colleges they have so much more Talent
than the teams they're playing you know
my wife Rhonda you could have won 10
games at University of Miami you know
but but if you don't play well in pro
football you're going to get beat
when you retired give me the job that
you almost came back out of retirement
for
first of all when I left Dallas you know
and I did Fox for a couple years
uh Philadelphia you know Jeffrey Louis
who's a good friend you know he talked
to me a couple different times uh and I
thought long and hard about it uh and
then uh McKay with Tampa I thought long
and hard about that one
uh Tom Benson came down Bob McNair came
down to Houston New Orleans and yeah I
thought about it Philadelphia one was
one that I kind of was interested any
college jobs but the bottom the bottom
line was I wanted to live here in South
Florida so that's why I ended up taking
the dolphin job
did you think about going back to the U
at all any any point oh oh no yeah I
mean I love University of Miami and
they're struggling right now but I think
they got the right head coach for Muriel
crispo I think they will be fine in time
but this is a struggle this year
it's amazing you've done all these
things but you're still identified as
the former Cowboys head coach it feels
like I mean that's the power of that
brand
um
do you give unvarnished opinions about
the Cowboys or is there question you
know sometimes the problem is anytime I
say anything about the Cowboys positive
or negative yeah that's going to be a
headline in Dallas and uh I mean you
know hey I'm not always right obviously
no one's always right uh but they're
going to ask my opinion and I'm going to
give it uh I mean I actually said A week
ago I thought this was the best cowboy
team that I've seen in a while now they
played poorly against Green Bay they
turned the ball over they didn't play
good run defense and that was a
disappointment but I think this is a
talented Cowboy statement in the NFC
you know there's four or five teams at
any one of the five could be in the
Super Bowl I don't think there's a great
team in the NFC yeah uh and so any one
of the five can make it there are a lot
of coaches former coaches uh of you know
front office people that were deeply
offended that Jeff Saturday moved in
front of the line for the Colts you as a
former coach and now analyst your
reaction
I don't know that I was offended I
understand it
and professional football only one vote
counts the guy that owns the team and he
can hire whoever he wants to hire uh and
I don't think we should be surprised by
any of them hiring because some of those
guys that owned the team you know maybe
they don't make good decisions now Jeff
Saturday a really a good guy he's been
around football a long time even though
he hasn't coached other than High School
uh I would say that you know there's
hundreds of
black and white coaches out there
they're a lot more qualified uh but I
wasn't offended
yeah I you know people jumped on it and
then he ends up winning that game and
then I wondered you know sometimes as a
head coach you have to let others do
their jobs when when you get to Sunday
just do your job maybe you don't coach
as much on Sunday as you do during the
week does that make sense well the one
thing Jeff Setter did he put uh Matt
Ryan back in there quarterback
I mean I mean so that he made one good
decision there
and and you know being the head coach uh
I think it's uh
the longevity is what you've got to look
at I mean it's a very difficult job
you've got to deal with a lot of
different people from diverse you know
backgrounds you got to deal with those
assistant coaches you got to deal with
you know 50 or 60 players uh so there's
a lot more to it than just coaching one
game is there a Michael Irvin's story in
the book
oh I'm sure Michael's in there somewhere
we've got Michael Urban stories we've
got Alonzo has Miss North hey one time
before we played Oklahoma we got some
stories about them calling Brian
Bosworth and then we got world wide west
and Leon Rose they drove my Corvette
from uh the NFC Championship Game to
Atlanta before the Super Bowl uh we've
got a lot of good stories in there
what's the craziest story though that
the ever encountered
the craziest story well actually the the
craziest story of uh when I was at
University of Miami is when Melvin
Breton and Alonso and and uh Jerome
Brown them called Brian Bosworth before
we play the morning before pregame meal
and said hey guys you awake you awake
well we're fixing to kick your ass
and then they come running to me in the
pre-game meals and Coach guess what we
did
what am I going to say I'm not going to
jump onto them
and which they they did but that was
part of swagger you know Michael Irvin
said you know hey you know part of
swagger and he said what we did he said
we're gonna you know we're gonna tell
you we're gonna kick your rear end then
we're gonna kick your in and then later
on we're going to talk about kicking
your rear end but he didn't say rear end
yeah I'm sure but coaching Somebody Like
Mike who you know had great Passion but
you always probably knew that you could
get a phone call at night that Mike
might be uh in trouble
Michael Who Never Was a problem now I
think after I left you know he got off
the rails just a little bit uh but it
was funny you know like if I hollered it
Emmett Emmett would go into a shell I
wouldn't get anything out of him the
rest of practice if I hollered it
Michael I could cuss him like a sailor
he had just worked that much harder you
know I hollered at Charles Haley a few
times Charles came my office and he said
coach I love playing for you just don't
embarrass me in front of the other
players so you had to know how to deal
with each individual how about Troy
I still love that story and I'm
paraphrasing but when you said that if
somebody fell asleep in a meeting I'd
cut him but yeah but if Troy fell asleep
in a meeting
I tell him to wake up
I told every team I said listen I'm
going to be very consistent I'm going to
treat every single one of you
differently
and and I said how I treat you the
harder you work the more you meet the
rules and regulation the more you do
what I ask you to do and the better
player you are the higher you are up on
the scale if you don't do those things
you're not a good player you got no
margin of error it's great to talk to
you the book is uh Swagger Super Bowls
brass balls and footballs we're talking
to Jimmy Johnson and get your copy
online wherever books are sold you look
great you sound great uh and uh
hopefully you do well with the book
Thank you again all right Dan hey enjoy
talking with you that's uh Jimmy Johnson
Hall of Famer take a break get phone
calls coming up Mike shazefski coming up
next hour